the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
again before we start there's a survey
online if you haven't done so some of
you have entered their answers in and
their their thoughts and I really
appreciate this it's actually very
helpful so you know seems that the
course is going fairly well from what
I've read so far so if you don't think
this is the case please enter your
opinion and tell us that we can make it
better
one of the things that was said is that
I speak too fast which is absolutely
true I just can't help it I get so
excited but I will really do my best ok
I will try to so just you know I think I
always start ok I just and not so well
all right so last time we talked about
this chi squared distribution which is
just another distribution that's so
common that it deserves its own name and
this is something that arises when we
sum the squares of independent standard
Gaussian random variables ok and in
particular why is that relevant is
because if I look at the sample variance
then it is a chi squared distribution
and the parameter that shows up is also
known as the degrees of freedom is the
number of observations minus one okay
and so as I said this Cakery
distribution has an explicit probability
density function and I try to draw it
and one of the comments was also about
my handwriting so I will actually not
rely on it for a detailed thing so this
is what the chi squared with 1 degree of
freedom look like and really would this
is it's just the distribution of the
square of a standard Gaussian right I'm
summing only one so that's what it is
then when I go to two this is what it is
3 4 5 6 7 10 and as I move you can see
this thing is becoming flatter and
flatter and pushing to the right ok and
that's because I'm summing
more squares and in expectation we just
get one at every time so it really means
that the math is moving the the mass is
moving to infinity in particular a
chi-squared distribution with n degrees
of freedom is going to infinity as n
goes to infinity another distribution
that I asked you to think about anybody
looked about looked around about the
student T distribution with the history
of this thing was so tell I'll tell you
a little bit maybe ya understand if you
have time so the T distribution is
another common distribution that is so
common that it will be used and will
have its table of quintiles that are
drawn at the back of the book now
remember when I mentioned the Gaussian I
said well there's several values for
alpha that we're interested in right and
so I wanted to draw a table for for the
Gaussian we had something that looked
like this and I said well Q alpha over
two right we get alpha over two to the
right of this number and we said that
there's a table for this things for
common values of theta well if you think
if you try to envision what this table
will look like it's actually a pretty
sad table right because it's basically
one list of number why would I call it a
table because all I need to tell you is
something that looks like this if I tell
you this is alpha and this is Q alpha
over two and then I say okay that
basically the three alphas that I told
you I care about or something like 1% 5%
and 10% and my table will just give me a
Q alpha over 2 so that's alpha and
that's Q alpha over 2 and that's gonna
tell me that I don't I don't remember
this one but this guy is 1.96 this guy
is something like 2.45 I think this one
is like 1.65 maybe and and maybe you can
be a little finer but it's not gonna be
an entire page at the back of the book
and the reason is because I only need to
draw this things for d1 standard
Gaussian when the parameters are 0 for
the mean
and one for the variance now if I'm
actually doing this for the K squared
the K squared I basically have to give
you one table per values of the degrees
of freedom because those things are
different there's no way I can take
right for gaussians if you give me a
different mean I can subtract it and
make it back to be a standard Gaussian
for the K squared there's no such thing
there's no thing that just takes the
case square with the degrees of freedom
ND and turns it into say AI square with
one degree of freedom this just does not
happen okay so there's no way to say the
word is standardized make it a standard
chi-squared there's no such thing as a
standard chi-square so what it means is
that I'm gonna need one row like that
for each value of the number of degrees
of freedom so that will certainly fill a
page at the back of a book okay even
maybe more I mean you know I need one
per sample size so if I want to go from
sample size one to 1,000 I need a
thousand rows okay so now the student
distribution is one that arises where
it's it looks very much like the
Gaussian distribution and if there's a
very simple reason for that is that I
take a standard Gaussian and I divided
by something that's how I get the
student what do I divide it with well I
take an independent chi square I've
known I call it V and I wanted to be
independent from Z and I'm gonna divide
Z by root V over D okay so I start with
a chi squared v so this guy is chi
squared D I start with Z which is n 0 1
I'm going to assume that those guys are
independent and my T distribution I'm
gonna write it T capital T is Z divided
by the square root of B over D why would
I want to do this well because this is
exactly what happens when I divide not
by the true variance a Gaussian but by
its empirical variance okay so let's see
why in a second right so I know that if
you give me some random variable let's
call it X which is n music
squared then I can do this X minus mu
divided by Sigma I'm gonna call this
thing Z because this thing actually has
some standard Gaussian distribution
I have standardized X into something
that I can read the quintiles up at the
back of the book okay so that's this
process that I want to do now to be able
to do this I need to know what new is
and I need to know what Sigma is
otherwise I'm not gonna be able to make
this operation mu I can sort of get away
with because remember when we're doing
confidence intervals were actually
solving from you so it was good that
noon was there when we're doing
hypothesis testing we're actually
plugging in here the mute that shows up
in h0 so that was good we had this thing
right think of MU as being p for example
but this guy here we don't necessarily
know what it is right I just had to tell
you for the entire first chapter I said
assume you have gaussian random
variables and that you know what the
variance is and the reason why I said
assume you know it and I said sometimes
you can read it on the side of the box
of measuring equipment in the lab so
that was sort of just the way I
justified it but the real reason why I
did this is because I would not be able
to perform this operation if I actually
did not know what Sigma was but from
data we know that we can form this
estimator SN which is 1 over N sum from
I equal 1 to N of X I minus X bar
squared and this thing is approximately
equal to Sigma squared that's the sample
variance and it's actually a good
estimator ok just by the law of large
number actually this thing by the law of
large numbers then goes to infinity well
let's say in probability goes to Sigma
square by the large number ok so it's a
consistent estimator of Sigma square so
now what I want to do is to is to be
able to use this estimator rather than
using Sigma ok and the way I'm going to
do it is I'm going to say ok what I want
to form is X minus
a mu divided by SN this time okay I
don't know what the distribution of this
guy is I just don't sorry its square
root of SN this is Sigma squared okay so
this is what I would take and you know I
could think of Slutsky maybe something
like this that would tell me well just
use that and pretend it's a Gaussian and
it's sort of we'll see how actually it's
sort of valid to do that because Slutsky
tells us it is valid to do that but what
we can also do is to say well this is
actually equal to X minus mu divided by
Sigma which I know what the distribution
of this guy is and then what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna just well I'm gonna
cancel this effect right Sigma over
square root SN okay so I didn't change
anything I just did a I just put the
Sigma here so now what I know is that
this is some Z and it has some standard
Gaussian distribution what is this guy
well I know that SN we wrote this here
maybe I shouldn't have put those
pictures because no I'm keep on skipping
before and after we know that s n times
n divided by Sigma squared is actually K
squared n minus 1 okay so what do I have
here I have that K squared so here I
have something that looks like 1 over
square root of SN divided by Sigma
squared right this is what this guy is I
just do some rewriting and maybe I'm
actually I actually want to make my life
a little easier I'm actually going to
plug in my n here and so I'm gonna have
to multiply by square root of n here
okay
everybody's with me so now what I end up
with is something that looks like this
where I have okay here I started with X
I should really start with okay I should
really start with a xn bar minus mu
times square root of n right that's what
the central limit theorem would tell me
I need to work with the average rather
than just one observation okay so if I
start with this then I pick up a square
root of n here okay okay so if I had the
Sigma here I would know that this thing
is actually xn bar minus mu divided by
Sigma times square root of n would be a
standard Gaussian right so that's if I
put xn bar here I really need to put
this thing that goes around the xn bar
okay
that's just my central limit theorem
that says if I average then my variance
is shrunk by a factor 1 over N now I can
still do this right that was still fine
and now I say that this thing is
basically okay so it's basically this
guy okay now so what I know is that this
thing is a chi squared with n minus 1
degrees of freedom
so this guy here is chi squared with n
minus 1 degrees of freedom let me call
this thing V in the spirit of what would
use there and in the spirit of what is
written here right so this guy was
called V so I'm gonna call this V okay
so what I can write is that square root
of n xn bar minus mu divided by square
root of SN is equal to Z
mine's square root of n divided by
square root of D okay everybody's with
me here which I can rewrite as Z times
square root of V divided by N and if you
look at what the definition of this
thing is I'm almost there what is the
what is the only thing that's wrong here
is this a state a student distribution
right so there's two things the first
one was that they should be independent
and they actually are independent that's
what Cochran's theorem tells me and you
just have to count on me for this I told
you already that SN was independent of
xn bar right so those two guys are
independent which implies that the
numerator and the denominator here are
independent that's what Cochran's
theorem tells us but is this exactly
what I should be seeing if I wanted to
have my sample variance if I want to
have to write this is this actually the
definition of a student distribution yes
No so see we see Z divided by square
root of e over D that looks pretty much
like like it is except there's a small
discrepancy what is the discrepancy
there's just the square root of n - one
thing all right so here V has n minus 1
degrees of freedom
and in the definition if V as D degrees
of freedom I divided by D naught by in
my but not by D minus 1 or not by D plus
1 actually in this case ok so I have
this extra thing well there's two ways I
can address this the first one is by
saying well this is actually equal to Z
over square root of V divided by n minus
1 times square root of n over n minus 1
right I can always do that and say for n
large enough this thing is actually
gonna be pretty small or I can take
account for or I can actually just I
mean I can compute it for any n you give
me I can compute this number and so
rather than having a t-distribution I'm
gonna have a t-distribution times this
deterministic number which is just a
function of my number of observations
but what I actually want to do instead
is probably use a slightly different
normalization which is just to say well
why do I have to define SN or always
myosin yeah why do I have to define SN
to be divided by n actually this is a
biased estimator and if I want it to be
unbiased I can actually just put an N
minus 1 here you can check that right
you can expand this thing and compute
the expectation you will see that it's
actually not Sigma square but n over n
minus 1 Sigma squared so you can
actually just make it an biased
that's called this guy tilde and now
when I put this tilde here what I
actually get this as tilde here and as
tilde here I need actually to have n
minus 1 here to have this s tilde be Chi
square degrees K square distribution
okay yes
yeah so basically this is what the story
did right so the story was well rather
than using always the central limit
theorem and just pretending that my SN
is actually the true Sigma squared since
this is something that's I'm gonna do a
lot I might as well just compute the
distribution like the quintiles for this
particular distribution which clearly
does not depend on any unknown parameter
D is the only parameter that shows up
here and it's completely characterized
by the number of observations that you
have which you definitely know okay and
so people said let's just be slightly
more accurate and in a second I'll show
you how the distribution of the T so we
know that if the sample size is large
enough this should not have any
difference with the Gaussian
distribution right I mean those two
things should be the same because we've
actually not paid attention to this
discrepancy by using empirical variance
rather than true so far and so we'll see
what the difference is and this
difference actually manifests itself
only in small sample sizes so those are
things that matter mostly if you have
less than say 50 observations then you
might want to be slightly more precise
and use T distribution rather than
Gaussian okay so this is just a matter
of being slightly more precise if you
have more than 50 observations just drop
everything and just pretend that this is
the true one okay any other question
okay so now I have this thing and I'm
actually so I'm on my way to changing
this guy so here now I have not rudin
but root n minus 1 yes and
is that true so I have a Z so this guy
here is s yeah where did I get my
written from in the first place yeah
because I wanted this guy and so now
what I'm left with is X and minus mu
divided by SN tilde which is the new one
which is now indeed of the form Z V root
n minus 1 which now I can write it as DV
n minus 1 and here I know that I have so
now I have exactly what I want and so
this guy is n 0 1 and this guy is K
squared with n minus 1 degrees of
freedom okay and so now I'm back to what
I want
okay so rather than using SN to be the
the empirical variance the were I just
divided by normalization is by n if I
use n minus 1 I'm perfect of course I
can still use N and do this multiplying
by root n minus 1 over N at the end but
it just doesn't make as much sense okay
so what's the story everybody everybody
is fine with what this TN distribution
is doing and why this last line is
correct all right so that's just
basically because it's of the form of
it's been defined so that this is
actually happening that's what that's
that was your question and that's really
what happened so who is this T student T
distribution where does the name come
from well it does not come from mr. T
and if you know who mr. t was you're
probably too young for that he was our
hero in the eighties and it comes from
this guy his name is shun William
Gossett 1808 so that was back in the day
and this guy actually worked at the
Guinness brewery in Dublin Ireland and
Janus mr. Guinness back then was a bit
of a fascist and he didn't want em to
actually publish papers and so what he
had to do is to use a fake name to do
that and he was not very creative and he
used the name student because I guess it
was a student of life and so here's the
guy who actually so back in 1808 it was
actually not
difficult to put your name or your pen
name on a distribution okay so what does
this thing look like it actually how
does it compare to the standard normal
distribution do you think it's going to
have heavier or lighter tails compared
to the standard distribution the
Gaussian distribution yeah right because
they have extra uncertainty in the
denominator right so it's actually going
to make things wiggle a little wider so
let's start with a reference which is
the standard normal distribution all
right so that's my usual bell-shaped
curve and this is actually the T
distribution with 50 degrees of freedom
all right so right now that's probably
where you should just you know stand up
and leave because you're like we're
wasting our time those are actually
pretty much the same thing and it is
true if you have 50 observations both
the central limit theorem so here okay
one of the things that you need to know
is that if I want to talk about T
distribution for say eight observations
I need those observations to be Gaussian
for real there's no central limit
theorem happening at eight observations
right but really what this is telling is
not that the central limit theorem kicks
in it's telling me that what what can it
would be what are these synthetics that
kick in there law of large number right
this is exactly this guy that's here
when I write this statement but it's
what this picture is really telling us
is that for n is equal to 50 I met the
limit already almost okay there's no
virtually no difference between using
the left hand side or using Sigma
squared and now I start producing 40 am
still pretty good we can start saying
that this thing is actually losing some
mass on top and that's because it's
actually pushing it to the left and to
the right in the tails and then we keep
going keep going keep going so that's at
10 you're gonna 10 there's not much of a
difference right and so you can start
seeing difference when you're at 5 for
example you can see the tails become
heavier and the effect of this is that
when I'm gonna build for example a
confidence interval to put the same
amount of math to the right of some
number that say I'm gonna look at this Q
alpha over 2 I'm gonna have to go much
farther which
is gonna result in much wider confidence
intervals okay
two four three two one
okay so that's the t1 obviously that's
the worst and well I if you ever use the
t1 distribution please ask yourself why
in the world are you doing statistics
based on one observation all right and
okay but that's basically with it so now
that we have this T distribution we can
define more sophisticated tests than
just take your favorite estimator and
see if it's far from the value you're
currently testing right that's that was
our rationale to build a test before and
the first test that non-trivial is a
test that exploits the fact that the
maximum likelihood estimator under some
technical condition has a limit
distribution which is Gaussian with mean
zero when properly centered and
covariance matrix or given by the Fisher
information matrix remember this Fisher
information matrix
I'm totally mmmm okay and so this is the
setup that we have okay so we have again
an iid sample now I'm gonna assume that
I have a d-dimensional parameter space
theta and that's why I talk about Fisher
information matrix and not just Fisher
information say number and I'm gonna
consider two hypotheses all right so
here I'm gonna have h0 theta is equal to
theta 0 h1 theta is not equal to theta 0
okay and this is basically what we
thought when we said are we testing is
if coin is fair or unfair so fair was p
equals 1/2 unfair was P different from
1/2 and here I'm just making my life a
bit easier okay so now I have this
maximum likelihood estimator that I can
construct because let's say I know what
piece data is and so I can build a
maximum likelihood estimator and I'm
gonna assume that this
Nicolle conditions that ensure that this
maximum-likelihood properly standardized
converges to some gaussian is actually
is actually uh are actually satisfied
and so this thing is actually true okay
so the theorem the way stated it if
you're a little puzzle this is not the
way i stated that and the first time the
way we stated it was that theta hat ml e
minus theta not so here I'm gonna place
myself under the null hypothesis so here
I'm gonna say under a zero and honestly
if you have any exercise on tests that's
the way that it should start what is the
distribution under h0 because otherwise
you don't know what this guy should be
okay so you have this and what we should
is that this thing was going in
distribution as n goes to infinity to
some normal with mean zero and
covariance matrix which was I of theta
which was here for the true parameter
but here I'm under a zero so there's
only one true parameter which is theta
zero okay that's what those were our
conditions for the this was our limiting
central limit theorem for I mean it's
not really central limit theorem
limited theorem for the maximum
likelihood estimator okay everybody
remembers that part the the line before
said under technical conditions I guess
so now it's not really stated in the
same way if you look at what's on the
slide here I don't have the Fisher
information matrix but I really have the
identity of Rd how do I turn a if I have
a random variable X which has some
covariance matrix Sigma how do I turn
this thing into something that has
covariance matrix identity how do I so
if I had if this was a Sigma squared
right well the thing I would do would be
divided by Sigma and then I would have a
one which is also known as the identity
matrix of r1 now what is this this was
root of Sigma squared right so what I'm
looking for is the equivalent of taking
Sigma and sort of divided
like the square root of Sigma which have
obviously those are matrices I'm
certainly not allowed to do and so what
I'm gonna do is I'm actually gonna do
the following
Sigma 1 over square root of Sigma
squared can be written as Sigma to the
negative 1/2 and this is actually the
same thing here okay so I'm gonna write
it as Sigma to the negative 1/2 and now
this guy is actually well define this is
just the so this is a positive symmetric
matrix and you can actually defined its
square root by just well taking the
square root of its of its eigenvalues
for example and so you get Sigma 1/2
equals and follows and 0 identity okay
and in general this guy has I'm gonna
see something that looks like Sigma 1/2
negative 1/2 Sigma Sigma a negative 1/2
okay and that's do all these things I
have minus 1/2 plus 1 minus 1/2 this
whole thing collapse to 0 and it's
actually the identity ok so that's the
actual rule ok so if you're not familiar
with this this is basic multivariate
Gaussian distribution computations take
a look at it if you feel like you don't
need to look at it but you know like the
basic just the basic maneuver it's fine
as well we're not gonna go much deeper
into that but those are part of the
thing that you know are sort of standard
manipulations about standard Gaussian
vectors because obviously standard
Gaussian vectors arise from this theorem
a lot ok so now I'm pre multiplied by
Sigma to the minus 1/2 now of course I'm
doing all of this in the asymptotics and
so I have this effect so if I pre
multiply everything by Sigma to the
one-half Sigma being the Fisher
information matrix at theta 0 then this
implies this is actually equivalent to
saying that square root of n all right
so now I have theta
not please the role of Sigma times theta
hat Emily - theta naught goes in
distribution as n goes to infinity to
some standard Gaussian multivariate
standard Gaussian and zero identity of
Rd and here to make sure that we're
talking about a multivariate
distribution I can put a D here okay so
just so we know we're talking about the
multivariate though it's pretty clear
from the context since the covariance
matrix is actually a matrix and not a
number oh yeah right thanks right so
yeah you're right so that's a minus and
that's a plus okay thanks so yeah what
is the anybody has a way to remembering
whether it's inverse Fisher information
or in Fisher information in the parents
than just learning it it is called
information right so it's really telling
me how much information I have so when
my variance increases I'm getting less
and less information and so this thing
should actually be 1 over variance the
notion of information is 1 over a notion
of variance okay so now I just wrote
wrote this guy like this and this the
reason why I did this is because now
everything on the right hand side does
not depend on any unknown parameter
right there's zero and identity those
two things are you know just absolute
numbers or absolute quantities which
means that this thing I call this
quantity here well what's the name that
I used started with a P pivotal right so
this is a pivotal quantity meaning that
its distribution at least it's
asymptotic distribution does not depend
on any unknown parameter moreover it is
indeed a statistic right because I can
actually compute it
I know theta0 and I know that I had
Emily one thing that I did and you
should actually complain about this is
on the board I actually used I played or
not and on the slides it says I of data
hat and it's exactly the same thing that
we did before do I want to use the
variance as a way for me to check
whether I'm under the right assumption
or not or do I actually want to leave
that part and just plug in the theta hat
Emily which should go to the true one
eventually or do I actually want to just
plug in the theta zero so with this is
exactly playing the same role as whether
I wanted to see square root of xn bar 1
minus xn bar in the denominator of my
test statistic for p or if i wanted to
see square root of 0.5 1 minus 0.5 when
I was testing if P was equal to 0.5
right so this is really a choice that's
left up to you and that's that's
something you can really choose the two
and as we said maybe this guy is lightly
more precise but it's not going to
extend to the case where theta 0 is not
reduced to one single number ok any
question all right so now we have our
pivotal distribution so from there I
have it
this is going to be my test statistic
I'm gonna use this as a test statistic
and declare that if this thing is too
large in absolute value right because
this is really a way to quantify how for
theta hat is from theta 0 and since
theta hat should be close to the true
one when this thing is large in absolute
value it means that the truth theta
should be far from theta 0 okay so this
is my new test statistic now okay I said
it should be far but this is a vector
right so if I want a vector to be far
two vectors to before I measure their
norm okay and so I'm gonna form the
Euclidean norm of this guy okay so if I
look at the Euclidean norm of an ax
and nuclear norm is the one you know I'm
gonna take it square because it's
actually let me not put a two here okay
so that's just the Euclidean norm and so
the norm of a vector X is just X
transpose X and this lights transpose is
denoted by prime well that's hard to say
put rhymes in quotes okay that's a
statistic standard that people do they
put trying for transpose everybody knows
what the transpose is okay so I just
make it file and I do it like this and
then that means that's actually equal to
the sum of the coordinates X I squared
okay and that's what you know as you
know but here I'm just writing it in
terms of vectors and so when I run to
write this this is equivalent this is
equal to well the square root of n is
gonna pick up the square so it gets
curative intent square root of n so n
this guy is just 1/2 so 1/2 times 1/2 is
gonna give me 1 and so I get theta hat
ml e minus theta and then I have e of
theta naught and then I get theta hat ml
e minus theta naught and so this thing
is my by definition I'm gonna say that
this is my test statistic TN ok and now
I'm gonna have a test that rejects if TN
is large because TN is really measuring
the distance between theta hat and theta
0 okay so my test now
[Applause]
it's going to beep sigh which rejects or
says one if TN is larger than some
threshold T and how do I pick this T
well by controlling my type on air this
is sorry the C by controlling my type 1
error okay
so to choose C what we have to check
check is that P under theta-not so here
it's data not that I reject so that sigh
is equal to 1 I want this to be equal to
alpha right that's how I maximize my
type 1 error under the budget that's
actually given to me which is alpha okay
so that's actually equivalent to setting
to checking whether P naught of T n is
larger than C and so if I want to
compute if I want to find this C all I
need to know is what is the distribution
of TN when theta is equal to theta
naught right whatever this distribution
is maybe it has some weird density like
this whatever this distribution is I'm
just going to be able to pick this
number and I'm gonna take the disk when
tau alpha here alpha and I'm gonna
reject if I'm larger than alpha whatever
this guy is so to be able to do that I
need to know what is the distribution of
TN under when theta 0 is equal to theta
when theta is equal to theta 0 what is
this distribution what is TN
it's the norm squared of this vector
what is this vector what is the
asymptotic distribution of this vector
yes
just look one board up what is the
synthetic distribution of this vector
for which we're taking the norm squared
it's right here it's a standard Gaussian
multivariate so when I look at the norm
squared alright so if Z is a standard
Gaussian multivariate then the norm of Z
squared Y by definition of the norm
squared is the sum of the Zi squared
right that's just the definition of the
norm but what is this distribution
that's a chi square right because those
guys are all a variance one that's what
the diagonal tells me all only ones and
they're independent because they have
only zeros outside of the diagonal okay
so that's really this follows some Chi
square distribution how many degrees of
freedom or the number of them that I
sell III sum D so now I have found the
distribution of TN under this guy and
that's true because here I'm this is
true under h0 right if I was not under
h0 again I should need and I would need
to take another guy here right the fact
how did I use the fact that theta is
equal to theta 0 when I centered by
theta 0 and that was very important ok
so now what I know is that this is
really equal why do I put 0 here ok so
this here is actually equal
so in the end I need see such that the
probability and here I'm not going to
put a theta zero I'm just talking about
the probability of the random variable
that I'm gonna put in there it's a
chi-square with D degrees of freedoms
exceed C is equal to alpha right I just
replaced the fact that this guy TN under
the distribution was just a chi-square
and this distribution here is just
really referring to the distribution of
a chi-square there's no parameters here
and now that means that I look at my Chi
square distribution we know it sort of
looks like this
alright and I'm gonna pick some alpha
here and I need to read this number Q
alpha okay and so here what I need to do
is to pick this Q alpha here for C so
take C to be Q alpha the quantile of
order 1 minus alpha of a chi-squared
distribution with this degree of freedom
and why do I say 1 minus alpha because
again the quantiles are usually
referring to the area that's still left
of them bye-bye
well actually it's it's by a convention
however in statistics we only care about
the right tail usually so it's not very
convenient for us and that's why I
rather than calling this guy Q sub 1
minus alpha all the time I write it u
alpha okay so now you have this Q alpha
which is the 1 minus alpha quintile or
quanta of order 1 minus F of Chi square
D and so now I need to use a table for
each D this thing is going to take a
different value and this is why I cannot
just spit out a number to you like I
spit out 1.96 because
i if i were able to do that that would
mean that I would remember an entire
column of this table for each possible
value of d okay and then I just don't
know okay so you need just to look at
tables and this is what it will tell you
often software will do that to you you
don't have to search through tables okay
and so just as a remark is that this
test wells test is also valid when I
have this sort of other alternatives
that I could see quite a lot right if I
actually have what's called a one-sided
alternative all right by the way this is
called Walt's test okay so taking TN to
be this thing so this is Walt's test
Abraham Wald was a famous statistician
in the early 20th century with Columbia
for quite some time and that was
actually at the time where India was
getting very we're statistics were
getting very popular in India and so he
was actually traveling all over India
and some you know dinky Plains and one
of them crashed and that's that's how he
died pretty young but he actually has
there's a huge school of statistics now
in India thanks to him there's the
Indian Statistical Institute which is
actually a pretty big thing and trained
the best statisticians all right so this
is called Walt's test and it's actually
a pretty popular test let's just look
back a sec so you can do the other
alternatives right as I said and for the
other alternatives you can actually do
this trick where you put theta zero as
well as long as you take the theta zero
that's the closest to the alternative
right you just basically take the one
that's the least favorable to you okay
to the alternative I mean okay so what
is this thing doing right if you did not
know anything about statistics and I
told you here's a vector that's the MLE
vector theta hat MLE
and I'm I'm so let's say this this theta
hat ml he takes the values
say okay so let's say theta hat Emmeline
takes values say 1.2 0.9 and 2.1 and
then testing a zero theta is equal to
one one two versus theta is not equal to
the same number
okay that's what I'm testing so you
compute this thing and you find this if
you don't know any statistic what are
you gonna do I you're just gonna check
if this guy is close to that guy and
probably what you're gonna do is compute
something that looks like the norm
squared between those guys so the sum so
you're gonna do one point two minus one
squared plus zero point nine minus one
squared plus two point one minus two
squared and check if this number is
large or not maybe you're gonna apply
some stats to try to understand how
those things are but this is basically
what you're going to want to do right
what waltz test is telling you is that
this average is actually not what you
should be doing it's telling you that
you should have some sort of a weighted
average actually would be weighted
average if I was guaranteed that my
Fisher information matrix was diagonal
if if my Fisher information matrix is
diagonal looking at this number - this
guy transpose I and then this guy might
is this that would look like I have some
weight here some weight here in some
weight here but if my matrix sorry it's
only three okay so if it has nonzero
numbers on all of its nine entries then
what I'm gonna see is weird cross terms
right if I look at some number pre
multiplied by some vector pre
multiplying this thing and post
multiplying this thing right so if I
look at something that looks like this X
transpose I of theta naught X transpose
we're think sorry X think of X as being
theta hat ml e minus theta so if I look
at what this guy looks like it's
basically a sum over I and J of X I XJ I
see they're not I J and so if none of
those things are 0 you're gonna not get
to see a sum of three terms that are
squares but you're gonna see a sum of
nine cross products and it's just weird
right this is not something standard so
what is Walt's test doing for you
well it's saying I'm actually going to
look at all the directions all at once
some of those directions are gonna have
more or less variance ie less or more
information and so for those guys I'm
actually gonna use a different weight so
what you're really doing is putting a
weight on all directions of the space at
once so what this Walt's test is doing
by squeezing in the Fisher information
matrix is placing your problem into the
right geometry it's a geometry that's
distorted in some where balls
become ellipses that are distorted in
some directions and shrunk in others or
depending on how if you have more
variance or less variance in those
directions those directions don't have
to be aligned with the axis of your
coordinate system and if they were then
that would mean you would have a
diagonal I information matrix but they
might not be and so there's this weird
geometry that shows up was actually an
entire field admittedly a bit dormant
these days that's called information
geometry and that's really doing
differential geometry on spaces that are
defined by Fisher information matrix
okay and so you can do some pretty
hardcore something that I certainly
didn't not do differential geometry just
by playing around statistical models and
trying to understand what the geometry
of those models are what does it mean
for two points to be close in some
curved space right so that's basically
the
so this thing is basically curving your
space okay so again I think I always
feel satisfied when my estimator or my
test does not involve just computing an
average and checking if it's big enough
right and that's not what we're doing
here we know that this theta hat Amelie
can be complicated
you know CF problem set two I believe
and we know that this Fisher information
matrix can also be pretty complicated so
here your test is not gonna be trivial
at all and that required understanding
the mathematics behind I mean it all
built upon this theorem that I just
erased they believed which was that this
guy here inside this norm was actually
converging to some standard Gaussian
okay so there's another test that you
can actually use so Walt's test is one
option and there's another option
and just like maximum likelihood
estimation and method of moments with
some time agree and sometimes disagree
those guys are gonna some time agree and
some time disagree and this test is
called the likelihood ratio test okay so
this parts those words likelihood ratio
test okay so at some point I'm gonna
have to take the likelihood of something
divided two by the likelihood of some
other thing and then you know work with
this and this test is just saying the
following here's this simplest principle
you can think of if you actually don't
even have to understand the notion of
like of statistical of likelihood in the
context of statistics you just have to
understand the meaning of the word
likelihood this test is just saying if I
want to test
h0 of theta is equal to theta zero
versus H theta is equal to theta one all
I have to look at is whether theta zero
is more or less likely than theta one
and I have an exact number that spits
out given a beta 0 or theta 1 and given
data I can put in this function called
the likelihood and they tell me exactly
how likely those things are right and so
all I have to check is whether one is
more likely than the other and so what I
can do is form the likelihood of theta
say 1 divided by the likelihood of theta
0 and check if this thing is larger than
1 that would mean that this guy is more
likely than that guy right that's a
natural way to proceed now there's one
caveat here which is that when I do I
part is the stain and I have this
asymmetry between H 0 and H 1 and so I
still need to be able to control what my
probability of type 1 error is and here
I basically have no knob all right this
is something if you give me data and
theta 0 and theta 1 I can compute to you
and spit out a yes/no answer but I'm not
I have no way of controlling the type 2
n type a type 1 and type 2 error so what
we do is that we replace this one by
some number C and then we calibrate C in
such a way that the type 1 error is
exactly at level alpha okay so for
example if I want to make sure that my
type 1 error is always 0
all I have to do is to say that this guy
is actually never more likely than that
guy meaning never reject and so if I let
C go to infinity then this is actually
going to make my type 1 error go to 0
but if I let C go to negative infinity
then I'm gonna have something that's I'm
gonna have my my oh I'm always gonna
conclude that h1 is the is the right one
okay so I have this trade-off and I
and turn this knob by changing the
values of C and get different results
and I'm going to be interested in the
one that maximizes my chances of
rejecting the null hypothesis while
staying under my alpha budget of type
one error so this is nice when I have
two very simple hypotheses but actually
to be fair we've actually not seen any
test that corresponds to real-life
example where theta zero was of the form
am i equal to say 0.5 or am i equal to
0.40 1 we actually sort of suspected
that if somebody asked you to perform
this test there sort of seen the data
before and they're sort of cheating so
it's either it's typically something am
i equal to 0.5 or not equal to 0.5 or am
i equal to 0.5 or larger than 0.5 but
it's very rare that you actually get
only two points to test how might this
guy or that guy now I could go on
there's actually a nice mathematical
theory something called the name and
Pearson lemma that actually tells me
that this this test the likelihood ratio
test is the test given the constraint of
type 1 error that will have the smallest
type 2 error so this is like the
ultimate test no one should ever use
anything different and we could go on
and do this but in a way it's completely
irrelevant to practice because you will
never encounter such tests and I
actually find students that you know
they took my class as sophomores and
then you know they're still around a
couple of years later they're doing
something they like I have this testing
problem and I want to use likelihood
ratio test
you know the neyman-pearson one but I
just can't because it just never occurs
I mean it just does not happen so here
are rather than going in the details
let's just look at what building on this
principle we can actually make a test
that work ok so now for simplicity I'm
going to assume that my alternative so
now I still have the dimensional vector
theta and what I'm going to assume is
that the null hypothesis is actually
only testing if the last coefficients
from R plus 1 to D or fixed numbers
okay so in this example where I have
theta was equal so if I have you know D
equals 3 here is an example H 1 H 0 is
Theta 2 equals 1 and theta 3 equals 2
okay that's my H 0 but they say I don't
actually care about what they don't want
is going to be ok so that's my null
hypothesis I'm not getting specified
right now what the alternative is that's
what the null is in particular this null
is actually not of this form it's not
restricting it to one point it's
actually restricting it to an infinite
amount of points those are all the
vectors of the form theta 1 1 2 right
for all theta 1 and say R ok that's a
lot of vectors and so it's certainly not
like it's equal to one specific vector
ok so now what I'm gonna do is I'm
actually going to look at the maximum
likelihood estimator and I'm gonna say
well the maximum likely similar
regardless of anything is gonna be close
to reality right now if you actually
tell me ahead of time that the true
parameter is of this form
I'm not going to maximize over all three
coordinates of theta I'm just gonna say
well I might as well just set one to the
second one to one the second one to two
the third one to two sorry and just
optimize over this guy right so
effectively you can say if you're
telling me that this is the reality I
can compute a constrained maximum
likelihood estimator which is
constrained to look like what you think
reality is so this is what the maximum
likelihood estimator is that's the one
that's maximizing so here the
log-likelihood over the entire space of
candidate vectors of candidate
parameters but this partial one this is
the constraint MLE that's the one that's
actually not maximizing over all Thetas
but only over the Thetas that are
plausible and they're denied our
hypothesis ok
so in particular what can I say if I
look at Ln of this constraint think that
I hat n see compared to L n see the Hat
let's say and M le so we know which one
were which one is bigger
the first one is bigger so what's the so
why so the second one is maximize over
larger space right so the first one so I
have this whole of theta which are all
the parameters I can take and let's say
theta zero is this guy I'm maximizing a
function over all this thing so if the
true maximum is this here then the two
things are equal but if the maximum is
on this side then the one on the right
is actually going to be larger all right
I'm maximizing over a bigger space so
this guy has to be less than this guy
okay so maybe it's not easy to see so
let's say that this is Theta and this is
Theta zero and now I have a function the
maximum over theta zero is this guy here
but the maximum over the entire space is
here okay so the maximum over larger
space has to be larger than the maximum
over a small space it can be equal but
they want the other one the bigger one
the one on the bigger space can be even
bigger however if my two theta
actually did belong to theta zero if h0
was true what would happen well if theta
zero is true then theta is in theta zero
and since the maximum likelihood should
be close to theta it should be the case
that those two things should be pretty
similar I should be in a case and not in
this kind of thing but more in this kind
of position
where the true maximum is actually
attained at theta zero and in this case
they're actually of the same size those
two things if it's not true then I'm
gonna see a discrepancy between the two
guys okay so my test is going to be
built on this intuition that if h0 is
true the values of the likelihood at
theta hat MLE and that the constrain MLE
should be pretty much the same but if
they're a hat if it's not true then the
the likelihood of the MLE should be much
larger than the MLE of the constraint
MLE that the likelihood of the
constraint Emily okay and this is
exactly what this test is doing so
that's the likelihood ratio test so
rather than looking at the ratio of the
likelihoods we look at the difference of
the log likelihoods which is really the
same thing and there's some weird
normalization factor too that shows up
here and this is what we get so if I
look at the likelihood ratio test so
it's looking at two times Ln of theta
hat ml e minus Ln of theta hat ml e
constrained and this is actually the
test statistic so we've actually decided
that this test statistic is what it's
non-negative right we've also decided
that it should be close to zero if h0 is
true and of course then maybe far from
zero if h0 is not true right so what
should be the natural test based on TN
let me just check that it's uh oh it's
already there so the natural test is
something that looks like indicator that
TN is large
see right and you should say well again
I mean you know we just did right I mean
it is basically the same thing that we
just did I agreed but the TN now is
different the TN is the difference of
log likelihoods whereas before the TN
was this theta hat minus theta naught
transpose identity a Fisher information
matrix theta hat minus theta naught when
this there's no reason why this guy
should be of the same form now if I have
a Gaussian model you can check that
those two things are actually exactly
the same right but otherwise they don't
have any reason to be and now what's
happening is that under some technical
conditions if h0 is true so now what
happens is that so if I want to
calibrate see what I need to do is to
look at what is the value of what is the
C such that this guy is equal to alpha
and that's for the distribution of T
under the null right but there's not
only one right the null hypothesis here
was actually just a family of things
right it was just just one vector it was
an entire family of vectors just like in
this example so if I want my type 1
error to be constrained over the entire
space what I need to make sure of is
that the maximum over all theta into it
or not is actually equal to alpha okay
yeah
so not equal in this case is gonna be
not equal I mean it can really be
anything you want it's just you're gonna
have a different type to there I guess
here we're sort of like stuck in a
corner we built this tea it has to be
smaller than a null and whatever the
null not the null is we just hope that
it's gonna be large so the the even if I
tell you what the alternative is you're
not gonna change anything about the
procedure okay so here Q alpha so what I
need to know is that if h0 is true then
TN in this case actually converges to
some chi-square distribution and now
here the number of degrees of freedom is
kind of weird right but actually what it
should tell you is finally I know when
you call this parameter degrees of
freedom rather than dimension or I'll
just be parameter it's because here what
we did is we actually pin down
everything but are so sorry we pin down
everything but our coordinates of this
thing right and so now I'm actually
wondering why
I think this should be a tie square with
our degrees of freedom let me let me
check and extend you an update about
this because the number of degrees of
freedom if you talk to normal people
they will tell you that here the number
of degrees of freedom is our right this
is what's allowed to move and that's
what's called a degrees of freedom the
rest is pinned down to being something
so here this Chi square should be a chi
squared R okay and that's something you
just have to believe me
anybody guess what theorem is gonna tell
me this well in some case is gonna be
Cochran's theorem okay there's something
that tells me that things were now here
I used a very specific form of the now I
turn ative and so for those of you who
are sort of familiar with linear algebra
what I did here is a zero consistent
saying that theta belongs to a R
dimensional linear space right it's
actually here the R dimensional linear
space of vectors that have the first or
coordinates that can move and the last
coordinates that are fixed to some
number okay actually it's an affine
space because it doesn't necessarily go
through zero and so I have this affine
space that has dimension R and if I were
to constrain it to any other or
dimensional space that would be exactly
the same thing and so to do that
essentially what you need to do is to
say if I take any matrix let's say
invertible let's call it u and then I
just say I want so H 0 is going to be
something like u is of the form u times
theta and now I look only at the
coordinates R plus 1 to D then I want to
fix those guys to some numbers so let's
call them I don't want to call them
Taylor so let's call them tau so it's
gonna be tau R plus 1 all the way to tau
D okay so this is not part of the
requirements but just so you know it's
really not a matter of keeping only some
coordinates really what matters is the
the the
mentioned in the sense of linear
subspaces of the problem and that's what
determines what your degrees of freedoms
are okay so now that we know what the
asymptotic distribution is under the
null then we know basically that we have
we know how to control we know how to
which table we need to pick our Q alpha
from and here again the table is a
chi-square table but here the number of
degrees of freedom is this weird D minus
our degrees of freedom thing I just said
it was our I'm just checking actually
fine yeah it's our it's definitely our
okay and okay
so here we've made tests we're testing
if our parameter theta was explicitly in
some set or not was it explicitly by
explicitly I mean we're saying is theta
like this or theta not like this it's
theta equal to theta not or theta not
equal to theta not are the last
coordinates of theta equal to those
fixed numbers or are they not writing
was something I was stating directly
about data but there's going to be some
instances where you actually want to
test something about a function of theta
not data itself for example is the
difference between the first coordinate
of theta and the second coordinate of
theta positive right that's definitely
something you might want to test because
maybe theta one is okay let me try to
think of some good example I don't know
maybe theta one is your drawing accuracy
with the right hand and theta two is the
drawing accuracy with the left hand and
I'm actually collecting data is for on
young children to be able to test early
on whether they're gonna be left-handed
or right-handed for example okay and so
I want to just compare those two with
respect to each other but I don't
necessarily need to know what the
absolute score for this handwriting
skills are okay so sometimes it's just
interesting to look at the difference of
things or maybe the some say the
combined effect maybe this is my you
know two measurements of blood pressure
and I just want to talk about the
average blood pressure and so I can make
a linear combination of those two and so
those things implicitly depend on theta
and so I can generically you know and
capsule them in some test of the form G
of theta is equal to zero versus G of
theta is not equal to zero and sometimes
in the first test that we saw G of theta
was just the identity right or maybe the
identity minus 0.5 right if G of theta
is theta minus 0.5 that's exactly what
we've been testing G of theta is theta
minus 0.5 and theta is P the parameter
of
a coin this is exactly of this form so
this is a simple one but then there's
more complicated ones we can think of
okay all right so now how can I do this
well let's just follow our recipe
everything we did was to try so we trace
back we were trying to build the test
distribution that was a test statistic
which was pivotal right we wanted to
have this thing that had no nothing that
depending on the on the parameter and
the only thing we had for that that we
built even or chi-square test one is
basically some form of central limit
theorem maybe it's for the maximum
likelihood estimator maybe it's for the
average but it's basically some form of
asymptotic normality of the estimator
and that's what we started from every
single time so let's assume that I have
this and I'm gonna talk very abstractly
let's assume that I start with an
estimator doesn't have to be the MLE it
doesn't have to be the average but it's
just something and I know that I have
this demeanor such that this guy
converges in distribution to some and
zero and have some covariance matrix
theta maybe it's not the Fisher
information maybe that's something
that's not as good as the MLE
meaning that this is going to give me
less information that the Fisher
information less accuracy and now I can
actually just say okay if I know this
about theta I can apply the multivariate
the multivariate Delta method which
tells me that square root of n G of
theta hat minus G of theta goes in
distribution choose some n0 and then the
price to pay in one dimension was paying
multiplying by the square of the
derivative and we know that in
multivariate dimension it's pre
multiplying by the gradient post
multiplying by the gradient okay so I'm
gonna write Delta G of theta transpose
Sigma sorry not Delta nabla G of there
okay so gradient and here I assume that
G takes values into RK right that's
what's written here G takes value from D
to K but think of K as being one for now
okay so the gradient is really just a
vector and not a matrix that's your
usual gradient for you for you know real
valued functions
okay so effectively if G takes values in
dimension 1 what is the size of this
matrix
I only ask trivial questions remember
that's rule number one it's one by one
right and that's you can check it
because on this side those are just the
difference between numbers and it would
be kind of weird if they had a
covariance matrix at the end I mean this
is a random variable not a random vector
okay so I know that this thing happens
and now if I basically divide by the
square root of this thing okay so for
this tape this the board I'm what I'm
working with K is equal to 1 divided by
square root of Delta G of theta
transpose Sigma Delta nabla sorry G of
theta then this thing should go to some
standard normal random variable right
standard normal distribution I just
divided by square root of the variance
here which is your usual thing now if
you do not have a univariate thing you
do the same thing we did before which is
pre multiplied by the covariance matrix
to the negative 1/2 so before this role
was played by the inverse Fisher
information matrix that's why we ended
up having I of theta to the 1/2 and now
we just have this gamma which is just
this function that I wrote up there and
could be potentially K by K if G takes
values into RK yes
yeah the gradient of a vector is just a
vector of it is the vector with all the
derivatives for with respect to each
component yes so you know the word
vector for derivatives but not for
vectors I mean the word gradient you
used for one-dimensional ok it's
derivative in one dimension ok
now of course here you notice there's
something I actually have a little
caveat here I want this to have rank K
right I want this to be invertible
I want this matrix to be invertible
even for the Fisher information matrix I
sort of needed to be invertible even for
the original theorem that was part of my
technical condition just so that I can
actually write Fisher inverse
information matrix inverse and so here
you can make your life easy and just
assume that it's true all the time
because I'm actually writing in a fairly
abstract way but in practice we're gonna
have to check whether this is gonna be
true for specific distributions and
we'll see an example towards the end of
this chapter
the multinomial where it's actually not
the case that the Fisher information
matrix exists the covariance matrix
these synthetic covariance matrix is not
invertible so it's not the inverse of
the Fisher information matrix because to
be the inverse of someone you need to be
invertible yourself okay and so now what
I can do is apply Slutsky right so here
what I needed to have is theta the truth
theta so what I can do is just put some
theta hat in there and then I'm just
writing that so that's the gamma of
theta hat that I see there and if theta
is true then G of theta is equal to zero
right that's what we assumed that was
our theta naught H naught was that under
h0 G of theta is equal to zero so the
number I need to plug in here I don't
need to replace theta here what I need
to replace here is zero now let's go
back to what you were saying here you
could say let me try to replace zero
here but there's no such thing there's
no G here it's only the gradient of G so
it's this thing that says replace theta
by the theta 0 wherever you see it could
not work here I could if G was
invertible I could just talk I could
just say that theta is equal to G
inverse of 0 in the know right and that
and then I could plug in that value but
in general it doesn't have to be
invertible and so and it might be a pain
to invert G even right I mean it's not
clear how you can invert all functions
like that and so here you just go with
Slutsky and you say ok I'm just gonna
put theta hat in there but this guy I
know I need to check whether it's zero
or not okay same right
P we did for theta except we do it for G
of theta now okay and now I have my
asymptotic thing I want to check I know
this is has a pivotal distribution this
might be a vector so rather than looking
at the matrix itself I'm going to
actually look at the norm rather than
looking at the vectors I'm going to look
at their square norm that gives me a
chi-square and I reject when my test
statistic which is the norm squared
exceeds the quantile of a chi-square
same as before just do it on here before
we part ways I wanted to just mention
one thing which is look at this thing if
G was of dimension 1 the Euclidean norm
in dimension 1 is just the absolute
value of the number right right which
means that what I'm actually computing
this this is actually so I'm looking at
the square so it's the square of
something so it means that this is the
square of a Gaussian and it's true that
indeed a chi square 1 is just the square
of a Gaussian but okay sure this is the
tautology but let's look at this test
now this test was built using waltz
theory and like some you know pretty
heavy stuff but now if I start looking
at TN and I think of it as being just
the absolute value of this quantity over
there squared what I'm really doing is
I'm looking at whether the square of
some Gaussian exceeds the quintile of K
square of 1 degree of freedom which
means that this thing is actually
equivalent completely equivalent to the
test so if K is equal to 1 this is
completely equivalent to looking at the
absolute value of something and check
whether it's larger than say Q alpha
over 2 well then Q alpha less you alpha
over 2 so that the probability of this
thing is actually equal to alpha and
that's exactly what we've been doing
before when we introduced test in the
first place we're just two capsules
values said well is the absolute value
of a Gaussian in the limit and so it's
the same thing so this is actually
equivalent
to the probability that the norm squared
is larger so that the chi-square of some
normal and that's the case the q alpha
of some K squared with one degree of
freedom
those are exactly the to say exactly the
two same tests okay so in one dimension
those things just collapse into one
being one little thing okay and that's
because there's no geometry in one
dimension there's just one dimension
whereas if I'm in higher dimension then
things get distorted and things can
become weird okay so
you